in this cloud minute I'll show you how
stackdriver Logging's exclusion filters
let you control what and how much you
log from the web UI click logging and
then click resource usage the top of the
page shows you your current usage and
what your projected log is usage for
this month is I can disable all the logs
for a specific product by clicking here
I can also exclude only messages that
match a specific pattern by clicking
create exclusion once I click I'm
redirected to the logs viewer and I can
search for the specific messages I want
to exclude I want to exclude all the
staff driver monitoring uptime checks I
do my search and it shows me the
matching log messages once I've created
a filter that works I put in a name for
the exclusion filter and then I can
decide what percentage of these messages
should be excluded in this case I want
100 percent now I click create exclusion
and messages that match my filter won't
appear in the log viewer but I can
export them if needed I hope this helps
you make efficient use of stock Trever
long